happy Wonderwoman week everybody there's
so much stuff when the DC Universe
that's happening this week I wanted to
do a timeline video to explain there's
like 15 plus DC films that are coming up
where everything fits in what the
correct order is to watch everything
since the movies out to I'm just doing a
giveaway for tickets all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video there for IMAX
gift certificates so because we're not
allowed to post our reviews till later
tonight I'm going to start with a
timeline for all the DC EU movies right
now and the funny thing is is that by
design is working out to be a lot like
the Star Wars match it a viewing order
where you start out in present day you
get a couple big reveals some big WTF
moments then you jump back to the past
to get some more context before jumping
back to the present to continue the
story in present day this is what the DC
EU looks like right now
after Wonder Woman there are 15 DC
movies that are in various states of
development less than half of those are
real movies right now like they announce
a movie title they attach a director
they start working on scripts you look
at some of these later dates like the
cyborg movie rape Fisher actually did a
comic-con event recently where he said
that that's still on track even though
there's been a lot of shuffling they've
changed what they're doing with the
Suicide Squad franchise they're still
doing a sequel for that so there's a lot
of stuff that could change later on but
this is the viewing order right now and
it's actually not as complicated as it
seems so I'll do two passes of this one
for the timeline for like when these
movies take place in a linear fashion
and then I'll do a viewing order because
that's a little bit different because
like I said machete a style you start
out in present day and you go to the
past to get some context to fill in
backstory then you come back to the
present and start carrying the story
forward starting with Wonder Woman
picking up in the thousands of years in
the past of the DC EU they sort of tell
the story of the origin of this world
the supernatural so gods all the really
crazy mystical stuff that we haven't
seen yet sort of setting the stage for
later things like Shazam black Adam
really cool really weird stuff then you
jump forward most of the movie takes
place during World War 1 so it's about a
hundred years before the events that we
just saw during Batman V Superman so
then next on the big timeline of events
you have the Man of Steel movie
Clark comes to earth is raised and you
have the events of that movie with the
Kryptonian attack that leads into Batman
V Superman you have that giant mess the
death of Superman Batman has a vision of
the future
thank you very much flash that something
is coming he sees Darkseid's Omega
symbol he senses the forces of
apocalypse we see parademons then
immediately after that you have the
events of Suicide Squad where he goes to
Amanda Waller to get files on all the
metahumans and then goes around at the
beginning of the Justice League movie
immediately after that to recruit
everyone flash cyborg Aquaman Wonder
Woman and they're still thinking about
Superman even though he's appeared
nowhere in the marketing materials but
because Batman world's greatest
detective just hasn't spent a lot of
time researching Kryptonian physiology
does not know that Earth's Yellow Sun in
the radiation will help heal Superman
that's why Batman is forming the Justice
League with the help of Wonder Woman
because they think that they're on their
own they need to bring together Earth's
heroes without the help of Superman one
of the really cool things that you see
in that Justice League trailer for the
first time is Aquaman in his full armor
we got a brief tease for him during
Batman V Superman and some of the other
Justice League members but here's where
it gets a little bit weird so if you
know how Black Panther is taking place
after Captain America Civil War but it
jumps around in the timeline during the
movie the same way the Wonder Woman
movie does that's kind of how the
Aquaman movie is going to work during
Justice League you see him in his full
armor he's wielding two Trident of
Poseidon he has his full powers he's
going to be totally badass
during the Aquaman movie right after
that you'll see a lot of threats to
Atlantean society obviously ocean master
is going to be one of the big
antagonists so it'll be very classic
Aquaman but they'll also use that movie
to tell a little bit about as origin
story things that they don't have time
to cover during Justice League so you
get the whole gamut of Aquaman you get
his past present and future in the
Aquaman movie and after that is where it
gets a little bit fuzzy like the Batman
movie is something that they're rolling
into production on you have the second
Justice League movie now depending on
how fast they get started with the
Batman movie if they can get it out in
time that will take place between
Justice League movies but if they don't
probably be a couple story edits and it
will take place after the second Justice
League movie
so the first Justice League movie is all
about setting up this external threat
from Darkseid Steppenwolf coming to get
the mother boxes in what they're calling
as the true birth of Superman in the DC
EU the best version of a comic-book
Superman that you could ever hope to see
in a movie the second Justice League
movie is about upping that threat so by
the time the second Justice League movie
picks up they'll have been working
together for a while it's the same thing
with the Avengers movies you form the
team in the first one the second one is
all about some grand threat that
requires all of them together on their
a-game so do not expect to see really
big Darkseid stuff till that second
Justice League movie hopefully
everything works out the Batman movie is
released before that and does the same
thing that the Aquaman movie does you
have a story that's mostly set in
present-day but you tell a little bit of
Batman's history that we haven't gotten
so far you fill in some context for this
dead Robin the Jason Todd version of the
character and then you sort of broaden
the mythology you deal with the
Nightwing the Batgirl characters in
what's going to be happening next so all
the characters will be informed by the
events that have preceded it so Batman
grows a lot because of the events of
Batman V Superman that informs his
character during Justice League he gets
raked over the coals during that movie
then that informs a lot of where his
characters at when the Batman movie
picks up it's the same thing for all the
other characters spin-off movies with
the exception of Wonder Woman they did
say that they're open to doing movies
that are set way earlier in the timeline
Wonder Woman is the opportunity for that
just because she's so long live so the
Wonder Woman sequel movie that they're
talking about now might still take place
before May enough steel in the timeline
but after that second Justice League
movie is where the timeline gets a
little fuzzy because the movies are in
various states of development so a lot
of this could change but the only movies
that they're definitely making right now
just to be determined when they're going
to take place and which characters are
going to be in them is the Black Adam
movie it used to be the Shazam movie but
now because the rock is such a big star
he's blowing it up so big and they have
not found their actor for Shazam what
they're talking about is that by the
time we get to that movie and we're
ready
that character after the second Justice
League movie is that they'll do a black
Adam story that'll take place in the
timeline after Justice League but
they'll use it as a way to surface the
Shazam character and show why he's
necessary so will it be more of a black
Adam Superman movie just because
Superman will have come back he'll been
reinvigorated hopefully everything works
out so Superman versus Black Adam then
Shazam appears during that movie then we
go on to a Shazam franchise if it all
works out you sort of have to add that
modifier just because there's so much
stuff that could change down the road
but you have the back row movie the
flash movie the cyborg movie Gotham City
sirens Suicide Squad - Nightwing Man of
Steel - in the Green Lantern Corps movie
so right now most of those movies are in
various states of development so we
don't know exactly when they're going to
take place or when they're going to be
released but for the most part we do
know because of the way they are
fast-tracking a lot of the Batman family
movies the Green Lantern Corps is still
sort of like the tail end of the DC EU
right now so we'll have a lot of these
earth-based movies even magic movies
before we get too crazy space cops
that's the timeline but now you talk
about rewatch is this is the viewing
order machete style
you start with Man of Steel oh my god
there's aliens how do we react to that
you get batman v superman what's the
next logical step people freak the hell
out then you get a Suicide Squad movie
then you jump back in time to Wonder
Woman then you jump back to present day
with Justice League then you get Aquaman
then you get your Batman movie then your
second Justice League movie and then
after that obviously it just depends on
how fast they get these movies going
they look like they're getting ready to
land on their Flash directors they still
have to finish that script so just
anything could change after the second
Justice League movie but let me know if
you have any questions about when these
movies take place there are a lot of
bookends in the Wonder Woman movie that
sort of tell you where you pick up and
where you end up place it relative to
Justice League but like I said most of
the movie takes place back during World
War one with a little bit of stuff that
takes place way before that where they
explain what happened thousands of years
ago there's been a lot of stuff going on
with the Batman movie lately Ben Affleck
just went back into training to get
ass in shape they'll start kicking his
butt and they'll finish that script my
non-spoilery Wonderwoman review will
post later tonight once the embargoes up
it was better than I ever could have
hoped I'm so happy I'm going to be
seeing it again later this week if you
have the opportunity be sure to go see
it in IMAX and because I'm doing the
ticket giveaway I'll announce a new
winner right now congratulations to
venture comics please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details there was a new
round of this video I'll announce the
winner the next time I post a DC video
later today there'll be some big DC TV
stuff happening to while you wait for
that you can click here for brand new
Justice League Nightwing and you can
click here for new flash thank you so
much for watching let's high-five I'll
see you guys tonight